Abbey is the boss at Gold's land dairy
farm but the rule she works to come from
two masters the EU and the Welsh
government with brexit those EU rules
will no longer apply and although she
voted to remain at these positive about
a new UK only approach but it's all
change there's no point getting down in
the mouth about it some of it is quite
exciting but the question of where EU
powers related to devolved issues will
go is not settled the devolved
administration's want full control of
decisions like how animals should be
tagged but the government says those
powers need in the first instance to be
retained by Westminster Abbey that makes
sense at the same time we don't have
these tangible barriers between England
or Scotland or Ireland and we need to
remain as one trading bloc so there has
to be this overarching policy that comes
out of Westminster that allows us all
this commonality otherwise we'd find it
very difficult to just do basic trade
within our own country but while the
Welsh and Scottish Government's accept
the need for a coordinated UK approach
they say the EU withdrawal bill severely
undermines devolution and demand it be
changed what the bill says is that
powers that would come from Brussels to
Wales will be hijacked and taken
straight to to wait all for an
indefinite period now clearly we can't
support that a refusal to endorse the
bill wouldn't be legally binding but the
First Minister warns ignoring devolved
administration's would have serious
implications if we withhold consent or
they override that consent well that
creates a crisis in terms of the the
fabric of the UK we've had two
referendums here in Wales where the
Welsh people have decided but they want
to have an assembly and secondly that it
should have substantial powers and
lawmaking powers those referendums are
as valid as the brexit referendum but
ministers say that concern is misplaced
the UK government position is that the
powers being brought from Brussels back
to Westminster by the EU withdraw bill
were not powers that the Scottish
Parliament or indeed the Welsh Assembly
had in the first place
instead they say that down the line what
will happen is that these devolved
administration's will have more powers
over all the Welsh conservatives in the
assembly here in Cardiff back that
position but even they knowledge that
some tweaks might be needed to the bill
there is a concern a debate to be had
about how long these powers will be held
in Westminster but to take the position
that nicola sturgeon and Carwyn Jones
have taken which is outright opposition
really is a farcical position to take
because when you think of all these
powers at the moment they're held in
Brussels anyway they're managed by a
bureaucracy that isn't elected by anyone
more pressure for bill changes could
come from the new crop of Scottish
Conservative MPs
one told Sky News they felt concerns
over its devolution impact were not
unfounded I want to know if the Scottish
Conservatives are truly Scottish
conservative standing up for Scotland or
are they just law before therefore
Tereza means direct disastrous hard
brexit but while the politicians argue
Abby needs to start planning for the
years ahead relying on them to start
talking to one another and agreeing
because we don't have a lot of time here
so it you know it needs to this process
just needs to get going because you need
clarity yeah I knew clarity I'm
operating the business here but a delay
is precisely what's happening while the
government considers whether its
prepared to swallow any of the proposed
devolution amendments to its brexit
plans Tom Rayner Sky News Cardiff